oh
beaucoup regardé ses grand retour du bec
de canard ou l'euro aujourd'hui ici à
berlin qu'est ce qu'on fait à berlin on
est venu voir vives eaux vives au maire
ces niveaux nous avoir invités alors
aujourd'hui on vient présenter un tout
nouveau smartphone que vivo va inaugurer
on a des ateliers on va regarder un peu
comment il est fait ce qu'il peut faire
connaissez vivo est un bien les
guillemots les indiens déstabilisation
ils aiment bien les vos écrans il aime
bien la technologie donc aujourd'hui
regardez le vive hausse et le x 80 pro
différents ateliers ont le test sera
dans quelques jours pour l'instant
l'idée c'est de regarder des gros
service et de comprendre comment il est
fait ce qu'on peut faire avec et puis on
fait des copains landes à brandon qui
tient la caméra savane playboy regardez
regardez le mort gardez moi ce beau
gosse lunettes de soleil des griquas
nasri est un peu notre zorro à nous quoi
exactement c'est un peu notre d'euros
merci beaucoup brandon knight olharan tu
peut la retenir avec beaucoup de
sympathie bien évidemment donc on se
laisse enfin tout conflit aura regardé
puis on sera le test dans quelques jours
tranquillement quand vous être et on y
va clap de début clap de début
on est gâté là on est on est au cinéma
de vivo vous installez les gars on va on
va signer mater c'est impressionnant et
installe t bien la toile canvas je suis
très bien ici confié l'international je
suis sur un choix côté de toi mon côté
de moi aussi je veux est brandon ouais
enfin il ya plus de soleil
alors bien de finir l'expérience soit
une expérience vivons aujourd'hui qui
nous présente ce nouveau smartphone
c'est le x 80 pro et alors je le
récupère et on se le test dans quelques
jours mais ce smartphone il est cool
parce qu'ils montrent plusieurs trucs
regardez c'est sale c'est le x 81 points
j'aime bien ces boîtes un peu carré chez
chez vivo il ya plusieurs trucs avoir
réussi avec ce smartphone le premier
gros points qui est intéressant c'est
bon alors au delà du design au delà du
module photo qui est quand même
différent ce qui va être intéressant ici
c'est effectivement d'avoir une zone qui
est beaucoup plus grande au niveau du
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous
posez votre doigt une fois et tout votre
doigt et scanner donc ça c'est cool star
mais plusieurs choses ça permet de
scanner rapidement se permet de choisir
différentes applications lorsqu'on vient
déverrouiller où l'on peut bien
enregistrer une empreinte digitale
regard des faits intéressants vous
mettez juste votre doigt vous le posez
une fois sa enregistre directement ça se
calme enfin c'est vrai ce moyen parce
que la zone en fait beaucoup plus grand
là vous posez votre doigt hoxha
déverrouille vous pouvez directement
ouvrir une application choisi et hop ça
ou directement contre le touquet quand
même vachement pratique hélas
directement sur la can a fait des petits
raccourcis et en fait comme la zone de
capteurs et beaucoup de monde eh bien on
peut le faire donc ça c'est malin l'adn
de vive hausse et l'innovation jeu pas
si vous le savez mais d'ailleurs vivo
c'est eux qui ont lancé le capteur
d'empreintes digitales sous l'écran ça
vient d'eux il ya également eu la petite
caméra pop up ça vient d'eux ce qu'ils
ont inventé donc vivo est là pour faire
de l'innovation c'est vrai qu'en france
vive hausse est pas la marque on va
connaître le plus c'est une marque qui
arrivé il ya à quoi il ya quelques
années qui prend son temps c'est lors
leurs idées c'est leur adn de prendre le
temps pour venir présenter des produits
ressasser plutôt un sac qu'un produit
mais venir présenter des produits qui
sont innovants qui sont sympas et qui
sont un peu différent alors différent
oui et non ça reste un smartphone avec
un form factor intéressant mais il ya
plusieurs choses ici ils sont super
intéressante et qu'on va me regarder
ensemble la première de ces choses c'est
la caméra guy mollet alors guinebault
louis et non pas partout l'idée de cette
caméra qu dean ball sais que vous allez
avoir une stabilisation de dengue et ça
avec moi c'est extrêmement important il
ya plusieurs autres avantages qui sont
intéressants c'est à dire qu'il ya un
truc qui s'appelle le maintien de
l'horizon c'est gopro qui fait ça là
vous allez prendre votre smartphone et
si vous bougez comme ça au même voulu
retourner vous avez gardé l'image droite
ça va pas bouger une oreille donc ça
c'est plutôt intéressant pas pour aller
se balader faire ça ça n'a aucun intérêt
mais si vous vous baladez vous marchez
et que ça bouge un peu comme ça ça ne
bougera pas et ça c'est bien c'est
intéressant choix qu'il est sur le zoom
optique faudrait que je regarde vraiment
ça mon contrat lors du test ça vous
permet d'avoir une stabilisation de
dengue dont vous allez venir zoom et
c'est vraiment l'idée est ici de
l'expérience photos et vidéos qui doit
être parfaite avec un super bon résultat
et pour avoir un super bon résultat ce
pas si vous mais vivent au travail avec
sachs s'est écrit ici là zaï zaï c'est
le spécialiste de l'optique d'ailleurs
lorsque on a utilisé une caméra à seul
bled pour aller sur la lune en 1969 je
crois et bien c'était une optique zeist
donc ils ont une vraie maîtrise au
niveau de la petite donc là ils ont fait
un gros boulot avec un pivot pour dire
ok on a un mode sachs pour apporter
vraiment l'image telle qu'elle doit être
pour quoi et bien parce que lorsque vous
allez faire de la photo sur smartphone
ce qu'on vient souvent recherché c'est
des photos un peu plus saturé pour
qu'elle soit jolie et qu'elle pète sur
les réseaux le mode zai celle inverse
c'est un mode proche du naturel proche
de la réalité on y ajoutait en jpeg mais
également euros pour venir est dit et ça
on le regardera bien évidemment pour
voir si le fichier est intéressant mais
c'est la promesse qui a fait ici c'est à
dire un vrai beau combo haut niveau ce
smartphone pourra venir filmer édité
s'amuser en photo ou en vidéo également
avec un mode portrait qui était fait en
partenariat avec zac l'enjeu c'est
plutôt chouette aussi mais également du
portrait nuit du portrait en vidéo bref
une solution qui est extrêmement
complète et d'ailleurs ils ont fait un
boulot ce n'est qu'ils ont mis de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va aider
à repérer les différentes lumières vous
allez avoir sur les scènes notamment
pour le mode portrait pour optimiser le
rendu donc à beaucoup de travail
derrière on va voir la vidéo boké à
effets cinématographiques
on a de la super night vidéo on a de la
vidéo ultrastar bref ils ont mis le
paquet regardez d'un point de vue
esthétique moi je trouve plutôt mais
alors on a effectivement un gros côté
rectangulaire sur l'eau avec la partie
photo qui est vraiment d accès qui est
vraiment sur le côté ça c'est assez
rigolo ça casse la symétrie là je pense
que si c'est le téléobjectif le
périscope qu'on va retrouver il ya un
côté miroir là on voit vraiment la drôme
voit un peu comme ça le flash led qui
est là on voit bien la petite griffe
jaïs d'un point de vue global moi je
trouve pas mal ce smartphone j'aime bien
cet écran qui est incurvé sur le côté en
corée mais pas trop où va pas jusqu'au
bout donc ceux qui aiment pas trop de
vin urbain ça n'a pas forcément les
déranger on voit que l'écran ils font
quand même tu crois 92 pensant la face
avant c'est ce que j'ai vu sur la piste
est qu on va retrouver le tireur de
cartes sim l'usb ici fatalement s'en
doutera du côté gauche on a absolument
rien de l'autre côté on a les boutons de
volume et boutons pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre en rien il ya effectivement
ce côté un peu asymétrique qui est un
peu différent de ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver sur le marché mais dans l'île
et j'aime bien à l'arrière on a retrouvé
un capteur grand temps capteur principal
de 50 méga pixels vous avez un ultra
grand-angle de 48 mégapixels un capteur
12 mégapixels pour le mode portrait sans
équivalent à 50 mm stabilisé optiquement
et vous avez un tel objectif de 8
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 5 et
on va jusqu'à x 60 bonfoh 60 c'est quand
même beau sans oublier la petite caméra
de celle fille de 30 2 mégapixels qu'on
va venir retrouver ici à la bombe un
smartphone qui risque dans une couleur
c'est ça c'est le cosmic black v 219 g
broc et moi je trouve pas mal il est un
poil largement en termes de prise en
main j'ai plutôt bien c'est d'aller le
tp aux 120 hertz de taux de
rafraîchissement d'elle évidemment
variable c'est un amoled e5 ultra vision
c'est le nom de la dalle et puis
regardez vous avez une très grande
diagonale ici de 6,78 pouces avec une
résolution wqvga des plus rien que ça au
niveau de l'audio on va retrouver des
haut parleurs stéréo alors attendez haut
parleurs sur le bas classique là est le
deuxième haut parleurs qui va être juste
sur le haut ici est un autre point qui
est pas mal c est la performance à
l'intérieur on retrouve bien évidemment
le saint dragonne 8 jane une première
génération mais il ya une autre puce une
puce de vie volant j'ai annoncé la
veille un plus qui va venir apporter en
termes de performances bien évidemment
qui va travailler avec le stand ragone
de huit gènes un qui va venir apporter
plus d'autonomie bien évidemment on nous
annonce également en termes de fluidité
de luminosité de colorimétrie de
résolution cette jolie promesse on verra
ça et après il ya aussi un autre travail
et je vous ai pas dit mais tout à
l'heure regarder au niveau des optiques
à l'arrière et bien vous avez les
objectifs caméra à l'arrière avec un
revêtement zeist et donc ça c'est pareil
pour venir les protéger plutôt
intéressant toutes les optiques zain
nous en montre on a eu des mots qui
était vachement intéressant pour il sait
comment ils travaillaient pour ne pas
avoir justement est bien de reflets pour
votre image qu'elle soit vraiment
parfaite extrêmement bien maîtrisée ici
de la part de zite refroidissement
liquide chambre à vapeur alors il existe
dans une configuration 7 12 giga de ram
c'est lui a fait 3 points et 256 giga de
stockage en lp ddr5 autant dire que
techniquement et technologiquement en
termes de performance vous avez ce qu'il
faut j'ai adopté cette puce voir si elle
apporte quelque chose là là l'avivo v1
plus je me rends pas compte on regardera
ses ensembles alors ici on a une grosse
batterie cdu 4700 milliampères heures et
on va de l'avant de la recherche filaire
80 watts vous permet de le recharger
jusqu'à 58 % en seulement 15 minutes et
à 100% en 35 minutes plus de la recharge
son fils c'est du cinquante watts qui
vous permet de le recharger à 100% en 50
minutes autant dire que ça va vite quand
même point de vue logiciel et bien c'est
fun touch funtouch funtouch pas si on va
le voir comme ça 12 basé sur l'android
douce bon c'est quand même pas mal on
verra ça également lors du test un peu
plus tard je vous montre également la
boîte comme ça vous verrez cette espèce
de gros trucs on vient l'ouvrir donc
normalement le smartphone est juste là
haut up qu'est-ce que j'ai ensuite ici
petite protection ok là les numéros de
série est ce que j'ai et un bloc de
charge ça c'est la question à sert
d'être très lourd je pense que j'ai un
bloc de charge qui est là ouais il est
dedans alors ça c'est cool parce que ça
devient un peu rare aujourd'hui au
niveau des smartphones d'avoir des blocs
de charge donc l'âge et de la recharge
rapide et de l'autre côté qu'est ce que
j'ai qu'est-ce que j'ai qu'est-ce que
j'ai une petite coque ok pourquoi pas je
pense qu'il ya un peu de dope la carte
de garantie mais bon là c'est assez
sommaire ce qu'on est dedans simple et
efficace ce qu'on attend d'un smartphone
donc une fois de plus ça ça me va bien
c'est un smartphone qui est certifié ip
68 résistants à l'eau et à la poussière
du wifi si du nfc bien évidemment donc
un smartphone qui a tous les codes des
smartphones haut de gamme puisque c'est
un smartphone haut de gamme il coûte je
vous le dis il est dispo le 30 juin
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je vois si
je peut choper un lien sinon je vous le
mets en bas
1299 euros c'est pas rien compris 1299
ans a quasiment 1300 euros ça c'est la
question est ce que vous vous pourriez
acheter un smartphone de vivo aussi
qualitatif soit-il quasiment 1300 euros
est ce que ça vous rassurerai ou est-ce
que vous iriez plutôt sur une marque que
vous connaissez un peu plus que vivo qui
encore un peu en outsider à en france
même si c'est un géant en asie et
notamment en chine dont ils ont un vrai
beau savoir faire ils le maîtrisent mais
ce que vous pourriez y aller vous
directement sur ce produit ou pas le
point qui retient l'attention c'est le
travail qu'ils ont fait en terme de
vidéo et photo donc c'est un smartphone
qui est dédié pour les créateurs pour
les créatifs qui veulent pas s'embêter
où des mecs comme moi qui ont
tremblement essentiel mais qu'ils
veulent quand même vachement bien filmé
qui veulent pas que ça bouge il me
semble que vive voix plutôt bien bossé
sur ce nouveau smartphone ne sortent pas
des caisses de smartphones vie vaut
peut-être qu'ils vont augmenter et
augmenter un peu le rythme mais pour
l'instant ce qu'on voit ici avec sa
basse et que et l'innovation une fois de
plus ils font des choses qu'on ne voit
pas ailleurs la caméra guim bol on la
voit pas ailleurs que très grand capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour l'instant je
n'ai pas encore vu ailleurs cette
deuxième puce qu'on a un côté plutôt
intéressant à voir on regardera sache
pas ce que vous en pensez vous comment
vous le trouvez se vivent au x 80 trop
est ce que ça pourrait vous tentez est
ce que ça pourrait vous plaire est ce
que vous pourriez pour
1299 euros ht ce smartphone chauffer un
peu cher mais je pense que ça lui vaut
les autres mac ferait la même chose on
se dirait salvo n'y a pas de souci mais
comme ces vivo une marque encore un pas
un outsider ici a tendance à se dire
c'est quand même cher donc dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
et qu on en reparle bientôt donc si vous
n'êtes pas abonné abonnez-vous comme ça
on regardera ensemble tester le tour
complet de ce smartphone ça va être
hyper chouette donc prenez soin de vous
embrasser à très bientôt pour continuer
à parler du vivo x 80 on voit la bise ou
bien on à berlin je souhaite aller bio
tchane